les élus du conseil départemental se
sont réunis en séance plénière ce mardi
28 juin dans l'hémicycle du palais de la
source
le lancement des premiers grands
chantiers en lien avec les trois piliers
de la mandature l'épanouissement humain
le développement territorial et
l'intelligence institutionnels les
conseillers départementaux ont voté la
création de maaf maisonde accueillants
familiaux un nouveau mode
d'accompagnement destiné aux personnes
âgées en situation de dépendance 5 maps
devrait voir le jour en 2016 va essayer
de trouver une alternative pour que le
grammont se sentent vraiment chez lui ce
sera une maison avec un jardin en coin
une chambre donc la map si vous voulez
ce rail mais son avec à peu près on va
dire 3 à 4 accueillants familiaux qui se
conformer par le département s'occupe
est donc de 12 à 2 10 à 12 personnes
dans un marché foncier agricole
restreint et alors que de nombreux
jeunes agriculteurs cherchent à
s'installer plus de 5000 hectares de
terres agricoles restent en friche et
conseillers départementaux ont donc voté
deux nouveaux dispositifs afin de
revaloriser les terres en friche et de
favoriser l'installation de jeunes
agriculteurs
sion un propriétaire non exploitants qui
souhaite vendre son terrain à un
agriculteur à un jeune agriculteur c'est
dû lui proposer une accompagnement de
l'ordre de 3000 euros l'état avec un
plafonnement à 20 mille euros est
également s'il souhaite mettre son
terrain à disposition à travers un bail
à ferme ça serait de lui accorder une
aide à 1500 euros pour pouvoir permettre
aux jeunes agriculteurs de pouvoir
s'installer sur son terrain nous avons
décidé d'accompagner le jeune acteur
lorsqu'il fait l'acquisition d'un
foncier son outil de travail
on va lui payer ses frais de notaire à
100% c'est important puisque ça veut
dire qu'on va l'aider à s'installer pour
quarante ans de vie 40 ans de carrière
lors de cette assemblée plénière le
département également adopté son nouveau
plan pluriannuel
mende une 17 2021 sur les cinq
prochaines années nous allons investir
près de 700 millions d'euros donc sur le
territoire de la réunion le conseil
départemental rencontrent des
difficultés en matière d'association
mais nous avons quand même une croix ce
volontaire de soutenir l'économie
réunionnaise
parce que vous savez c'est quand même
les chefs d'entreprise c'est le btp qui
créent de l'emploi pérenne et à travers
notre patrimoine à travers nos bâtiments
nos routes
nous avons la possibilité de pouvoir
faire faire des travaux par ces
entreprises et donc par là même soutenir
l'activité économique
parmi les autres dossiers présentés ce
jour la mise en place du programme
départemental d'insertion 2016 2018
l'une des priorités de cette mandature
nouveau plan départemental natation avec
une innovation la bourse d'emploi
destiné à tous ceux qui sont les plus
éloignés de l'emploi que nous mettons en
oeuvre avec les amp e pôle emploi
pourquoi pas ce que nous allons essayer
de leur offrir en travail partenarial
les meilleurs postes qui correspondent à
leur profil
et puis aussi un plan ambitieux pour
avoir un guichet unique pour pour ce
jeune ou ceux moins jeunes en demande
d'associations air référent unique pour
qu'ils n'aillent pas frapper à toutes
les portes
on peut encore faire mieux puisque nous
voulons signer un partenariat avec
également les communes sur et les
missions locales sur les microrégions
existantes à la réunion
des dossiers qui ont été votées à
l'unanimité par l'assemblée
départementale